[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to stories untold now this
odd game is kind of like that one game
that was based on a bunch of VHS tapes
that you found that I played last year
but it wasn't this game
it definitely wasn't this game this is a
game about four different stories taking
place at once and that's literally all I
know about it oh hey how you doing Oh
[Music]
earth
that's kind of a lot like stranger
things I'm just gonna go ahead and say
that right now that's very much very
much like the opening this stranger
things but I'm not gonna overlook that
this game's highly reviewed I know very
little about it but it's cool oh okay hi
it's Pony Islands hello the house
abandoned sorry you could stop that
anytime now oh you pull up to the
driveway of the family holiday home and
park the car it's dark but it's as
idyllic as you remember from all that
time ago you remember being told to look
in the glove box before going in it's
good to be back I'm sorry I don't
understand I'm sorry I don't understand
wait oh look in glove box open glove box
it's a text-based adventure game I
haven't played one of these inhale well
I guess I'm not playing in it oh there
we go inside is a key and a handwritten
note from dad read note the note is from
your dad and reads hi son hope you enjoy
your break you'll need to fire up a
generator around back to get foul and
light song also found something in the
attic for you it's in your room enjoy oh
come on come on let's go come on I got
places to be got things to do okay uh
open glove box Hey oh I guess I took the
key okay get out of car this is like the
last one I played it was don't [ __ ] your
pants that was the last typing based
game I've ever seen the house is grand
Sat perfectly amongst the trees in front
of you is the front door and the yard
stretches around the side of the house
look at house
look sorry look at house the lights are
all off no one else is here go around
side take a walk around the yard the
yard has been well-maintained
you spent a lot of time here with your
family on holiday trips good memories
alright look around generator on the
back wall the house turn on generator
you switch the generator on any worse to
life the house is still dark that's ok I
got the generator on go to front you
walk back around to the front of the
house I know how this works look at tree
look around oh the trees stretch up to
the night sky there's a house in the
yard look at yard spaces yard just
around the back that's a great place to
relax in the long summers ok go in house
door appears to be locked you will need
- ok unlock the door you insert the key
and turn the door clicks open ok open
door there we go you enter the house to
the hallway it's dark and you can't see
anything you feel a light switch next to
the door however flip switch flip light
switch there we go let's come on dot dot
dot the hallway is now brightly lit
there is access to the kitchen and
living room here as well as a set of
stairs going up go in catch it the
kitchen is tidy and well-kept there's a
door - utility room but otherwise it's
just a kitchen eat food open refrigerate
or look around
exit kitchen go in living room you step
inside the living room a spacious and
comfortable living room we spent a lot
of good time in here playing board games
with the family warm and inviting looked
around
there's nothing here of interest ok good
no go back go upstairs
you walk upstairs to the landing the
stairwell landing there was a bathroom
and two bedrooms yours and your sisters
pictures adorn the walls images of a
happy times look at pictures family
photos and holiday snaps our happy
family go in sister's bedroom you walk
into your sister's old room your
sister's room is in perfect condition
untouched since the last time you'd seen
her posters of her heroes and some of
her own attempts at art adorn the walls
a few shelves are crammed full of
trophies her bet is drowned under a pile
of colorful soft toys a real nostalgia
trip look around there's also a large
wardrobe in the corner of the room the
door slightly ajar okay
login wardrobe large clothes wardrobe
use unusually the door slightly ajar she
never liked you going through her stuff
open wardrobe it is empty apart from the
pile of scattered photographs at the
bottom look at photographs they are all
identical a forest road at night you put
them back leave I want I want to
perfectly admit I love text-based games
because it's all in your mind it's just
like the thing that's standing behind
you right now it's all in your mind
don't look at it because then it becomes
real same as this thing staring at you
from your window go in your you walk in
your old room your old bedroom so many
good memories in here and it's been
preserved so well on the desk is a
gift-wrapped box look at box mm open box
you unwrap the gift excitedly you can't
believe it dad has found your old
computer a future Oh 128 K plus 2 it's
been preserved well in the attic and
hopefully still works
ah always good to dig up old computers
and whatnot and open them both reckless
abandon Oh a copy of the house abandoned
play the house all banned
I don't know what you're trying to use
future oh I don't know you're trying to
use play computer use computer you start
to plug in the various cables and leads
the computer is all set up and ready to
go there's a game here - yeah play game
you put the cassette in the computer and
press play
[Music]
okay whoa ah oh oh no um all right this
is cool I'm okay with this this is all
good I like this this is great I'm so
happy about this don't you they were
about my club if it's dark was clearly
neglected you remember being told to
check the glove box before going in you
can't stand to be near this place open
glove box insides a key take both
reading note you don't recognize the
handwriting
it says games great well what's that
thing staring at you from your closet
and did you leave your room door open
like that I don't think you did exit car
you forced the Warped card door open and
fall out the house looks off granted
there is a yard in the side Wood creaks
in the wind and all the happy memories
are gone from this place there is no
love here okay I feel the love
look for love look at house the lights
are off windows are broken
there's the front door and a yard okay
go around the back where would you like
to go go around the side
you step through the debris in the
backyard the grass is overgrown that was
tough anyway and the weeds crawl up the
side of the house it's not a nice place
to be
you clutch the note needing to look
around look around there's an old
generator next to you a break generator
turn on generator play smooth jazz for
the generator
Oh No that's not good
there isn't much fuel but the generator
starts up go back open door oh no you
wouldn't dare do that to me it's black
but your senses are punished more by the
smell stale air and damp this could not
be less inviting the note burns in your
hands you feel compelled to read it over
and over reading note it's too dark to
read but it feels weird to the touch
touch no sorry alright flip on light
switch afraid of what you might see you
flick the light switch the lights
flicker on and off the walls are falling
apart after years of neglect or worse
there's stains in upstairs the sounds of
someone who's in the house they should
not be here there's a kitchen and a
living room adjacent the stairs leading
up the note feels disgusting in your
hand the note feels bigger in your hands
feel note notes I can't read the note
it's bleeding that's normal going and
kitchen you go into the kitchen the
kitchen stinks and feels completely
unfamiliar the tabletops are rusted
metal and there's a carcass on the table
there's writing on the wall and the
utility room door has a red X painted on
it I didn't know about the utility room
that I didn't know about look at carcass
you look closer but can't tell what it
is or what it was
eat carcass you are disappointed in
yourself for even going there
eat carcass okay go in utility room the
door is locked I can't get in there not
yet look around
it seems to be writing on the wall and
what looks like blood
read writing in blood the number 1986 is
smeared across the wall okay what does
that mean okay back in the hallway your
shoes are wet the noises stop but you
feel a presence someone is in the house
they should not be here there's a
kitchen and a living room adjacent the
stairs leading up oh end living room you
enter the living room the living room
although hardly an appropriate term
because everything is dead the
furnitures threadbare and worn the note
is fixed in your mind dread fills the
pit of your stomach is not a nice place
run down an empty abandoned and for good
reason look at furniture the furniture
looks disgusting there's no way you'd
sit on it sit on furniture no chance
reading note the note always changing
now reads get through this I don't care
if you want to or not ah okay leave you
can't back in the hallway I think we
have to go upstairs now you head up the
stairs that creak same but different the
landing has access to your sister Shay
no you don't understand neither can he
all right
look around you can't focus the ringing
in yours is too much
read note care what you say okay answer
phone your mind hurts in it you taste
iron voices spill out of the phone into
the room whoever's in there should not
be there you need to hang up the phone
I do whoever you consider the worst look
around you can't hear yourself think
it's too much hang up
relief relief same but different the
landing has access to your sisters
sisters from your room and the bathroom
pictures all over the wall the wall
something is different about them look
at pictures the pictures are of your
family the eyes have been scored out on
all and go in bathroom you've entered
the bathroom the bathroom feels
disgusting and every surface is covered
in a layer of oily grime the sink is a
haven for all kinds of bugs eat bugs
look at bugs look around a broken mirror
hangs above the dirty sink
taps rusted in position look in mirror
you can't bear to look at yourself why
don't look in your mirror you never know
what's coming back okay let's leave step
back onto the landing and her sisters
from Jennifer's room is boarded up you
can't bear this enter my room the door
is bolted shut with a four-digit
combination lock
you grab the lock the lock is rust if
not used in years the key in your hand
weighs heavy the note heavier you grab
the lock and can now and put the code
even note the note is reacting get in
the door get in the room get in I only
owe 1986 oh that would probably be it
okay 1986 the lock clicks open oh [ __ ]
oh boy that's not good that's not good
go in my room the doors closed open my
door hi friend how you doing I'm not
sure which room you would like to go go
in my room you entered your bedroom
[Music]
the bedroom feels utterly familiar
the walls are damp but you've been here
before in front of you a lone person
sits in front of a computer screen the
lamp is on the clock reads nine nine
nine nine you should be here you could
then know tight
I'm sorry Jennifer I'm sorry mom I'm
sorry dad you haunt every step I take
even in this place I was out of my hands
but still you punish me I can be with
you now there's nothing left to do I'm
consumed and confused this has to end
now leave room you can't leave here this
is where it has to end rocking back and
forth consumed by guilt I looked at the
person hug of first sorry okay um you
are pathetic it was all your fault say
it it wasn't my fault oh please stop I'm
not guilty it was all my fault say it it
was not my fault to say it no no no no
no you first
no it was all my fault
f I and O al l why
pippity poppity reputable oh that was
fascinating but what did I miss
that's what I got a that's the thing
about all these text-based games there's
always secret codes and stuff that you
can poke in and you can know about and
then you can find out who the place was
there multiple endings to that it wasn't
just all very linear because it seemed
very linear towards the end I was really
trying to explore all right that was
super cool
I looked it up apparently there aren't
any secrets in the first chapter at
least in the first chapter I'm not sure
about the second ones I didn't want to
see just in case I didn't want to spoil
anything for myself but that was really
cool I'm curious if the next one is
going to be similar to that I don't know
for sure but I want to find out so I'm
gonna play the next one and then I might
finish up three and four in another
episode all right let's do the lab
conduct this is so cool this is so cool
I love this I love the style of it the
storytelling of it can I skip this okay
and in the lab itself our volunteer mr.
Asian we have artifact 23 in the chamber
recovered from crash site B at a moment
it appears inert showing no signs of
activity
mr. Jian instructions for each stage
will come through to your terminal and
we need you to follow up exactly now
some of this may be unfamiliar so always
reference the manual on your terminal
for guides on calibration and procedure
once you've calibrated equipment to
match our brief the green light will
flash allow you to trigger the
experiment one last thing
ensure that any equipment non-essential
to the current experiment it's switched
off you cannot proceed until your
calibration that matches oh I don't
understand anything that you just said I
have no idea anything that you were
talking about what were you talking
about
oh oh oh
clicky oh my god oh I have no idea what
this all is oh but it's so cool that's
all hard oh okay alright alright let's
turn this off cuz they said something
about turning off unnecessary equipment
so I'm gonna let it do exactly that okay
at the chamber use your mouse cursor
okay manual Oh hmm this is that's a lot
of that's a lot that's a lot of things
that's a lot of things that you're
trying to teach me how it's like I'm
back in engineering school I don't
understand anything that you're talking
to me about okay drill press oh no you
safety goggles and gloves at all times
okay do not leave the container under
tended during experimentation if there's
extremely dangerous to handle any items
within the container please ensure your
next of kin is updated at HR
this is not safe six okay all right well
experiment x-ray the artifact determine
its internal structure okay
x-ray camera monitor charge CC 86 x-ray
device okay so I need the camera
I need the monitor I need the CC 86
x-ray device camera monitor set to x-ray
okay
CC 86 is a blow the drill this thing
charging alright bang boom here we go
let's begin so it's dead but I don't
think that's a good idea where is this a
human heart is so alien her demon heart
due to surface reaction attempt
demonstrate the effects of laser light
on the object try using a low powered
red laser to begin with Oh Oh easy okay
laser light generator 650 nanometers
monitored RGB okay let's turn the
monitor RGB laser 650 go baby go both
freaking green okay green green is 510
okay all right
okay we have a reaction of some sort
here a weak signal let's keep going
increase again okay I don't know I'm no
scientist blue okay blue blue is 455
easy peasy put four or five five and
bing-bang-boom
[Applause]
why do we have a pulse why why do we
have a pulse why is there a pulse why is
there a pause
acoustic resonance yeah let's blast it
with sound wait only 250 Hertz sine wave
with amplifier games set to 1 okay
signal generator amplifier okay ah
signal dinner and turn the laser off
crank that [ __ ] to 50 and one good let's
see what happens okay yeah sure all
right okay all right 505 you got it baby
you got anything for you big papa Bing
okay go oh no oh it's not happy
[Applause]
okay around was even move route against
how what do you mean we're running out
of time what do you mean we're running
out of time
switch to square wave okay square wave
it is oh that's probably not good I'm a
really yeah real good
oh good no truck I don't trust you I
don't trust you at all
alright maintain gain five in the square
form bring wave wave form up to one
Killa hurt you got it boss
oh yeah let's see it this feels good it
feels good yeah he's real good
there's good stuff this is good good
stuff mm-hmm
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay here you've made it excellent
progress you're doing great now we need
you to stay calm try to relax as we go
through these next steps what wait what
happened what happened what is what
happened what do you mean what happened
the protective casing is off proceed to
the drill to drill this surface wait we
saw we popped off the heart this is how
puppet dad we just sploded the heart
okay we're sure drill sure all other
equipment except the Cameron TV are
switched off okay alright camera off off
okay here we go this is gonna be great I
don't know what the hell this is
oh how do you feel very scared we have
the situation under control
take a few moments and when you're ready
we'll continue I don't feel good why is
it I don't feel good I feel bad make
contacts with oh okay open her up but a
big metal boom
clunk hello hi
oh sorry about your heart I'm afraid I'm
afraid I'm sorry to have to do this but
we have to know I know how difficult
this must be
but you can do this
it's time to remember what are we
remembering also that's a hell of a
flashing light ah my eyes
you're a proxy now you have a connection
to the entities in a core
Wow
it's like a conscious black box
it can show you its memories look into
it
the visions will translate onto the
screen to be something that you can
understand oh you can play out oh good
great oh great let's do this whatever it
is here we go
great oh oh no no no no no here we go
again you wake up in the cryopod okay
struggling against gravity you force
yourself up impact into the planet's
surface has torn a hole in the ship hull
poisonous atmosphere spills into your
craft you were in grave danger you have
to get out of here
look around the craft is broken beyond
repair
there's wreckage all around an airlock
door is locked tight in the computer
terminal adjacent blinks look at
computer monitor blinks demanding
attention the system looks usable use
computer you tap at the screen in the
airlock door splutters to life slowly
opening with a horrendous noise the ship
powers down - silence having spent the
last of its reserves okay open door was
taken from what we think
these memories are different and unlike
the others there's more detailed here
that's hazy Reena see whatever hi here
we go
thank you juice is great
okay thank you thank you thank you so
much thank you very much I appreciate
that
you squeezed through the damage to
airlock and fall to your knees on the
ground next to your vehicle every breath
brings pain to your chest you look
around to see you are surrounded by
mangled metal bright lights pour through
every gap in the surrounding wreckage a
crash site smoke billows from the downed
ship exterior lights flicked on and off
wreckage surrounds you looking upwards
you see unfamiliar star patterns some of
this metal will have to be moved in
order to free yourself move metal with
every ounce of your remaining strength
you move away enough of the wreckage for
you to carefully call through the lights
that surround you now attack your senses
a circle of artificial lights surround
you set up to illuminate the crash site
in the darkness behind them an army of
people all staring one figure steps out
a silhouette and walks towards you look
at figure the silhouette is bipedal and
bulky some sort of mask covers its face
and beckons you to approach Oh
but you're doing well for what it's
worth very few of our test subjects ever
making this far
you should be proud of yourself not
battlefield proud that doesn't reassure
me in any way shape or form that doesn't
reassure me at all thank you for that
thank you for that we awake the room is
silent only for the quiet helm of
equipment and occasional machine beep
your touch isn't yours we are all as one
we move together in unison we are in a
bed in a small artificially lit room
with a single door there's some sort of
writing pin to the wall it Jason is a
display monitor with wires that drape
across the room and into our chests
when did this happen Oh a series of
wires leave the machine and run across
our chest attached in different places
we aren't sure if the black fluid is
going in or coming out collective
discomfort the fluid looks thick and
dark we can feel a transfer but not
which direction stuck together a series
of flat sheets with symbols across them
some sort of writing we can't reach the
door effectively tethered to the machine
remove wires
whoa we yank at the wires protruding
we yank at the wires protruding from our
chests
together we all scream in pain this
action sets off an alarm at going loudly
down the adjacent corridor
that vision it's not a memory it's
happening right now in station I need
you to stop what you're doing I don't
know about that I need to get more daily
dose of vitamin light oh okay well
that's oh great great thank you thank
you for that thank you thank you thank
you through the door we find ourselves
in an empty room with a device on the
table it looks familiar they don't know
how it works but this host does the door
closed behind us in a lock clamped shut
we are alone together it is some sort of
preparation room there are markings on
more sheets with the door and a window
on one side the door we came through has
been locked shut
and the other door has an orange alarm
light above it in the center of the room
a table holding only a small device
taken from your it's my our ship it was
an access code terminal for a wide
connection allowing commanders to
commandeer other hosts only you I we
have access to these codes it's time to
use them use terminal all
please we deeply regret what we've put
you through but please understand it was
for the greater good we had to know more
now we don't know what this might do to
you in the long run there we go got it
just had to look into the light for a
little bit longer
[Music]
hello
okay I'm gone I'm going for this
willingly Oh
[Music]
one day stationed this room won't you I
don't know what I did I'm not on a
passenger what I did at all what I feel
good about it I feel good that was a
weird one what I like it this is so cool
this is so cool so that is the first
half of untold stories a really
interesting game nice to play these
types of games as a kid a lot and they
were always fun because it felt like the
world was a lot bigger than it was and
kind of combines having a game today
where you can have this environment in
this world and you can do the
storytelling through that great art and
whatnot but you can also let the
imagination take you and feel like you
have some input on it there are some
with withdrawals from that like just in
terms of like not being able to do
everything you want to type in but
limitations are there but thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to see the other two episodes of
this from me let me know down the
comments below if you want to see other
scary games that I've done I'll put them
in the description so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
[Music]